MANOMARKS: Hi.
I'm ManoMarks, developer
advocate on the Google Maps API
team.
This is the first video in a
series of four videos designed
to get you started with the
Google Maps JavaScript API.
At the end of this
series, you will
have a fully functional
Google Map in your app.
In this series, we will cover
creating your first map,
getting an API key,
loading the maps API,
and we'll walk through the code.
This video will show you how
to create your first map.
You'll need a web browser, an
internet connection, and a text
editor.
Many people use Text
Edit or Notepad.
In this episode, I'll
use Sublime Text 2.
First, put your browser to the
Google Maps API sample code.
You can do that by clicking
on the annotation here.
You see a page with the
map centered in Australia.
Click on the JavaScript
plus HTML tab,
and then select
and copy the code.
Open your text editor
and paste the text.
Now save the file somewhere as
an HTML file with the extension
.html.
For testing purposes,
I'm always lazy
and save to the desktop, where
I know I'll find it later.
Double click on the file
to open it in a browser.
You should see your map
as a tab in your browser.
OK.
Let's customize this by
changing the start location.
What we want to do
is change the center
of the map and the zoom bubble.
First, let's choose a latitude
and longitude pair to use.
You can use any
latitude longitude pair
in decimal form
for this purpose.
I'm going to use 0, 0.
OK.
Now say it and go back
to the web browser,
and reload the page.
You should see a map like this.
Pretty much all water.
What we've done is chosen a spot
off the West Coast of Africa.
We zoomed in too
far to see anything.
So go back to the text editor
and change the zoom parameter
from eight to six.
Now reload the page,
You'll see that you're
zoomed farther out.
In the Google Maps
API, lower zoom levels
are farther away from the
map, while higher zoom
levels are closer.
So level zero shows the map
of the Earth fully zoomed out.
Zoom level 19 will show a map
with streets and buildings.
OK.
You've made your first map.
In the next video, I'll show
you how to create an API key.
Using an API key enables you to
monitor your application's maps
API usage, and ensures
that Google can contact you
about your application
if necessary.